after Strindberg lagoon off and gobble
ingmar bergman has today the only
international eminence created in and
through swedish heart and in and through
his vision his films have influenced the
whole world these motion pictures
provide his deeply personal view of the
human condition perhaps because he is a
director who is by definition a writer
and a writer who is by extension a
director and the producer of both the
images he conjures up our extreme
abnormal picturesque apparitions of
death flagellation which burning cruelty
and horrors and startin li parallel to
these mortality and immortality
marriage and family old-age the need for
self-knowledge and compassion and what
it is really like to be alive today and
he always wants to know exactly what he
is going to do and because he has
succeeded so brilliantly in converting
his own emotions and dreams into
objective audience experience we salute
him with the Irving Thalberg award given
given from time to time to that
filmmaker who has been responsible for
consistent excellence innovation and
integrity in the literature of the
screen because his work makes it
impossible to join us tonight he has
sent a lovely surrogate lady who has
starred in many of his films including
persona our of the wolf the shame and
the passion of Anna a Norwegian actress
who has made her success in Sweden and
who fortunately for all of us speaks
delightful English it is exciting to
welcome miss leave almond
this is my first visit to Los Angeles
and I have enjoyed every moment of it I
met a lot of warm generous people and I
am very happy that Ingmar Bergman asked
me to represent him on this big occasion
though I would have been more happy if
he himself could have been here tonight
getting personally all the respect and
love which has been shown him he has
asked me to say to you that he's sitting
on his little island in the Baltic
writing on a new script he isn't here
because he feels that a long trip at
this moment would do great harm to his
concentration on work and he believes
that he shows his respect and
gratefulness to the honor bestowed to
him by the board and members of the
Academy by staying home finishing his
script and he also feels that this
fantastic award will inspire him in his
fulfillment of his work in my Bergman
says I am deeply touched and very very
grateful
you